[Music]
[Music]
february 2022 and ukraine was under
attack
russian forces launched a full-scale
invasion of the country bringing war to
europe for the first time in decades
millions of families were terrified
about what would happen to them they had
to flee their homes to find somewhere
safe to live
and many of them came to neighbouring
countries like poland my parents
are now in ukraine and they stay
there to defend our country we try to
become and
we believe in our country and in our
soldiers a lot in this special edition
of fyi we're hearing from ukrainian
families whose lives have been ripped
apart by war and we're following them on
their long journeys to reach safety
leaving behind their loved ones
i'm terrified of the thought that
someday i will call them and they will
not respond
[Music]
this
is the first time i've seen for myself
what war looks like away from the front
line
[Music]
children
sometimes on their own
traveling across a continent to seek
safety
[Music]
the main crossing points for people
escaping from the war zone is the
village of medica in poland
over there just beyond the border post
is ukraine and you can just see this
flow of people desperate to reach safety
from february onwards millions of people
have made this journey
i've seen them arriving here frightened
and worried about what will happen to
the loved ones they've left behind
very very worried i'm trying to
text them every day every hour because
they're very
scary message from news channels in kiev
it's like
a key of
bombs it's very scary
many of them have been through so much
just to get here witnessing terrible
things during their long journeys
sometimes there are friends from poland
who are here to meet them
and we've seen some emotional reunions
but there are also people in need of
help from complete strangers
to see this mass movement of people it's
really eye-opening i mean i'd seen
pictures and videos on tv of course
but to actually be here and witness it
in person feels completely different i
mean these people have been through the
absolute worst experiences witnessing
war all around them and i can just see
in their faces how exhausted they all
are
susanna from a polish scout group is one
of the people who have been helping out
always with a friendly smile to make the
refugees feel welcome and safe we are so
upset but we don't want to show them to
people because we want them to be braver
we are smiling and we try to give them
our good energy
there are like one kid and she was in
tears when i was giving her sweets and
she gave me chocolate
because she wanted to give me like a
present for
to thank me for this
it's really the little things and people
are just doing whatever they can to help
anyone in any way i mean to carry bags
donating anything and just giving out
little toys and doing anything they can
to cheer up for kids who you know never
had to should never have had to witness
any of the things they've seen
[Music]
in a nearby town a reception center has
been set up in an old supermarket
it's a place where the refugees can rest
and look for advice on finding somewhere
to live
we found a banker from london who was
volunteering as a chef in one of the
food tents
it's a real eye-opener like i'm i'm
absolutely devastated
the inside of that tesco's when we went
in there around midnight 1am there were
kids still awake but most of them are
lined up along the sides like imagine
your grocery counter full of kids just
to sleep in their winter clothes and it
hit around minus 5-6 last night
it really was not a nice
a nice experience
seeing the welcome that refugees have
been given from people all over europe
is great but don't be fooled into
thinking that it's easy being a refugee
through no fault of their own these
families have lost everything
their homes their possessions
their schools
their security
near the railway station we met 17 year
old elia who'd been traveling for 20
hours with her eight-year-old niece
arena and a friend with a one-year-old
they were cold and exhausted so we took
them into a cafe for something to eat
then elia told us why she decided to
flee her home in the ukrainian city of
hakov
we heard the
bomb attack somewhere far away from our
house but then
it was like growing louder and louder my
parents and i just
we just couldn't leave because of our
grandparents and it was impossible but
then the missile
hit our house
[Music]
our ninth floor was destroyed and
that was the moment when i realized that
i gotta go and
i just
couldn't leave my parents alone but i
had no other choice so what was it like
having to leave your parents behind
it's kind of hard for me even to think
of it
because i have my i have tears in my
eyes because i don't know it was like
the most
terrifying experience that i ever had
and when you just need to look in your
parents eyes
when you gotta leave without them
and they don't know how
how your way will be and with who we
will be and where
i don't know but
i guess
i guess it makes it easier that we have
our phones and we just can connect but
i'm terrified of the thought that
someday i will call them and they will
not respond
[Music]
i just can't imagine what that must be
like
always worrying about your mum and dad
and whether or not they're okay
in a city that's been under constant
attack
elia's big dream was to come to the uk
to study international relations at
university
but for now at least that ambition has
been put on hold
because of all of this happening my
dreams are just crushed they are just
destroyed
a polish man we met in the cafe offered
to give the group a lift to the city of
rotsworth more than five hours away
we've all been told about stranger
danger at school
so just like all the people we featured
in this program we checked him out and
saw that he just wanted to help
and not only did he drive them to
vrotswath he also gave them money to
help them find somewhere to live
i kept in touch with elia and you'll see
how she got on later
[Music]
with ukrainian men asked to stay behind
to defend their country nearly all the
refugees are moms and their children
but in the city of krakov we met
twelve-year-old vadim and his 18 year
old sister katarina who were trying to
reach friends in another country
slovakia
their parents like many others had
stayed behind in ukraine they stay there
to defend our country they wanted for us
to come here it's really bad
so i must say that
we have really work in our country
children can't do nothing so i
really back
adults to protest in such way in
anything to stop this world to stop this
really
bad thing in our country
we were so worried about katarina and
vadim so he decided to keep in touch
with them and two weeks on from their
difficult journey to slovakia i've
arranged to hook up with them on my
laptop
hi katarina so how are you after that
long journey from ukraine
i must say that we are almost okay
we are safe
anyway and it's better for us to stay
here now
than in ukraine unfortunately i just
can't choose words to say thank you very
much
because this support is
a very huge and it's great theme that
people from all over the world support
ukrainian in terrible time for us well
we're so glad that you're safe now thank
you so much for talking to us
thank you
[Music]
not everyone who crosses the border from
ukraine has somewhere safe to stay
back at the refugee reception center we
met thirteen-year-old sasha and his mom
karina who'd arrived in poland with no
idea where they would live
i want to woke up and don't hear
guns rockets and
and so on
that's why we come here
luckily they spotted a sign on a car
this couple had driven a thousand miles
from their home in the netherlands to
offer refugees a place to stay we can
bring them to holland and give him a
good stay over there for a long period
once again we wanted to make sure that
sasha and karina would be safe with the
dutch couple and after all the adults
discussed their offer of help it was
decided they would travel to the
netherlands
i'm very happy it's just amazing
they had a long journey ahead of them
and a few weeks later we found out sasha
and karina were really well
after a few weeks living with the dutch
couple they moved into a hostel in the
city of leyden
[Music]
also making a long journey
these refugees were heading to denmark
they will have almost likely never been
to denmark but the danish government is
offering them a safe place to stay
i've heard that it's not been so easy
for refugees who want to come to the uk
but to get to denmark there were no
forms to fill in and the process
happened within just a few hours of them
crossing the border into poland
the journey to reach denmark took 15
hours through the night
[Music]
but at the other end
safety
and the promise of a comfortable home
for as long as they needed it
it's the country's neighboring ukraine
that have taken in most of the refugees
that's moldova romania hungary slovakia
and poland
as for the uk
well our government did also agree to
take in thousands of families but
there's been anger that the process to
let people in has been too slow and too
difficult
it's a criticism i put to the prime
minister boris johnson when braden and i
met him in downing street
we've got an amazing record as a country
for taking people in we're seeing
massive generosity already by the by the
british people but i know that the visa
application process is really really
complicated so how are you going to make
it easier some people have said well you
should get rid of checks all together
and you should just let people in
without any any any chance i just don't
think that is
practical because
at the moment if you look at what's
happening in ukraine it is a nightmare
you've got a lot of people who aren't
necessarily who they say they are
you know some
fast checks i do think are sensible but
i think getting rid of checks all
together is not a good idea
[Music]
there was just one more person i wanted
to catch up with
two weeks after she arrived in the city
of rotswaff i wanted to meet ellia again
to see what had happened to her
so how has life been for you since
moving to rotsworth well i was just
trying to forget all of the nightmare
things that i've been through when you
see the sky with no missiles and with no
smoke
of course you can understand that
it's like a different world and of
course you can't believe it till
the moment when you realize that your
family is still in this other universe
that you've left i know that you were
really worried about your parents so how
are they and how's their home city right
now
now it's almost destroyed and all of the
buildings i used to look at when i was
younger nothing of this is existing
right now it's just destroyed
but
i know that my parents are staying
positive they tell me that everything's
be okay and the missile
won't touch them anyways because it
already did and they say that missiles
don't
hit one place two times
and
it's the only thing that
that i hope will work out and that it is
true and
yeah that they will be saved in the end
of all of this i know you've just had
your 18th birthday it must have been so
strange without your parents around
yeah of course but
you know it was like lightened with the
fact that
i heard their voices yeah i heard their
voices and they were safe and sound and
it was like the best birthday present
that i ever got
so yeah have you been able to make any
decisions about your future
the decision is just not to give up yeah
and just to keep my chin up and to set
up new goals and achieve them well i
think you're so strong and i really do
hope that you get to go to the uk and
study
thank you
[Music]
it was great to meet ellie again and
maybe with her determination not to let
the war crush her dreams
she can play a role in helping ukraine
to have a peaceful future
but in the meantime the nightmare goes
on for the ukrainian people
families remain separated
and people continue to cross the border
just to find somewhere safe to live
i can only imagine what it must be like
for the refugees here having their whole
lives turned upside down overnight
none of these people ever thought that
this would happen to them and we've got
to do what we can to help this is 2022
and we're in europe this shouldn't be
happening it really should not be
happening
[Music]
you